[Music]
[Music]
is the xbox III 2018 briefing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
please welcome the head of Xbox bill
Spencer
[Applause]
with Halo Infinite we will join Master
Chief on his greatest adventure yet to
save humanity we're now at a moment of
exceptional creativity in gaming we
can't wait to show you what creativity
Unleashed looks like for you so all the
gamers around the world across time
zones and languages to every single
person watching us on TV and on mixer
and to our largest ever live audience
the thousands of you with us right here
in the Microsoft theater
welcome to e3 2018
I'd like to personally thank everyone
who's joining us from fan fest
[Applause]
[Music]
a hundred percent of the proceeds from
your fan fest tickets are going to
gamers outreach thanks to you kids and
children's hospitals get to game with
their friends in their favorite worlds -
great cause that's what I appreciate
most about gaming gaming brings us
together gaming connects us it inspires
our truest cooperation it creates some
of our fondest memories of competition
and our deepest conversations about the
stories within games most of all gaming
fosters real community it reaches across
age ability race gender and geography
this is why I've always believed and
will always believe that gaming is the
great unifier and what unifies us is our
shared love of this artform legendary
characters who captivate us not just for
10 hours
but for 10 20 30 years bold stories that
inspire the hero within us iconic worlds
that are so richly imagined we feel
excitement in the air and danger on the
seas as gamers we are at a momentous
time where creative vision and
cutting-edge technology together are
delivering the artform we love so for
months our teams and I have traveled the
world meeting developers from Japan to
Poland from the UK to the Ukraine from
big studios to single developers
creators who sees the full power and
potential of Xbox one to express the
remote daring vision for games today
we've curated a bold showcase of their
best work and ours 50 games 18 titles
with exclusive
and 15 world premieres some will be
first-timers on this stage and others
will be first-timers on any stage all
are imagined by the industry's greatest
talents I'll demonstrate what true
artisans can create mind-blowing art
immersive sound effects breathtaking
worlds so let's jump in
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
world premiere
[Applause]
so you're awake
[Music]
looks like death is not your fate just
yet
some time has passed since I found your
your master still lives they'll soon
make use of his blood ID
lost will give away to something more
you'll learn to appreciate it's worth
your death or to come easily
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
please welcome from Bethesda Game
Studios hi how
[Applause]
[Applause]
how's everybody doing oh it's great to
see everybody again you know actually
the Bethesda event is a few hours right
after this across the street and Phil
said to me I'm having a few friends over
why don't you stop by and look I know
Phil is really really charming but then
he's got a lot of friends and the good
news is you're our friends too we've had
an incredible 16 year history with xbox
going all the way back to the original
with morrowind now backwards compatible
and that goes all the way to bringing
mods to consoles with fallout 4 and now
we are bringing the Fallout universe to
Xbox game paths with fallout 4 launching
today
and hey since we're here we thought we'd
give all of you an exclusive world
premiere first look at fallout 76
yes fallout 76 is a prequel to all the
other games and it is our biggest one
yet it is four times the size of fallout
4 set in the hills of West Virginia you
are one of the first to emerge into an
untamed and very different wasteland
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
300 years after our great nation began
we gather together to honor the
completion of vaults 76 this sprawling
underground shelter may have been
engineered by voltec but it was built by
you so that if the bombs do come our way
of life will endure
almost heaven
West Virginia
it's mountain
[Music]
life is all
and the tree
[Music]
like the country
[Music]
there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
for when the fighting is stopped in the
fallout a settled
you must rebuild not just walls not just
buildings but hearts minds and
ultimately America itself
[Music]
involved 76 our future begins
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
world premiere of my silence I can't
hear you I don't know where to begin I
don't know where to be
[Music]
it's just me captain spirit this is
Chris of Flying Fortress have you
spotted snowman sir not yet keep me
posted
breakfast you're drinking beer I don't
need a lecture for my son I always get
picked last for his team at school and
they never throw the ball to me they
can't tell stories like you can can they
no way
[Music]
you
this time you won't get away from me
[Music]
I'm a slow smile me too nobody's ready
you're probably gonna change the world
just I hope so I know so
[Music]
the awesome adventures of captain spirit
download for free from June 26th
[Music]
exclusive commander Jack on deck welcome
to crackdown 3 the only game built like
me it's all about getting this jump on
the enemy no building is to live 60
stories up
they build up that walk where would grow
more namah namah namah bigger
then you need to fire homing rocky good
for tech kid
Gravatar agenda have you two met and the
most powerful weapon of
me and then I roll up like a boss I can
push our fools pull up the side of a
building or even bust out my barrier
oh yeah
well quit they got miss man science and
madam master bang
Malcolm
we're back
crackdown three
[Applause]
we will take that our world from the
scourge of the machine
glory to mankind
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and the skies rained me silence and the
ground burned to ash and the Seas boiled
and people turned into shadows so let us
not fear standing before us stinking of
machine remember most of the country has
been destroyed or occupied even those
who speak our language might be enemies
by conviction or out of fear way we're
not faltered let us steal ourselves
against them for this is our hour of
glory amen
let's move out Artyom
[Music]
they want blood they will give it will
cost of no matter what those fanatics
think
[Music]
and they're the ethics come for our
lives we will stand firm
so you got me your dietary things
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Metro had me at its gritty visuals
brutal landscapes in its mystery of the
ruins above-ground what I love about our
art form is the vast range of creative
expression from grim post-apocalyptic
battles to hand painted spirit Guardians
whatever world these creators filled
whatever story they tell whatever sound
effects they use we will work with
creators to guarantee that their games
look and play best on Xbox one like this
next game generations have loved
role-playing games from invented Studios
in Japan our next game is the latest in
a legendary series for the first time
ever on xbox Kingdom Hearts
[Applause]
it's cold
Jessie's to use to the beach hey
Islander what can I say look even the
seas turning to ice
[Music]
a walking talking snowman you really are
alive
hello Olaf are these our friends hmm
nope
never met him don't know anyone blue
green or Osaka spike
[Music]
me
give me strength
whoa
[Music]
oh look out
[Applause]
that's amazing you can control ice
control it
no all I ever do is hurt people this is
my home now I can't go back I don't want
to hurt anyone
[Music]
[Music]
things they don't really
oh you're probably gonna pretend I have
a dream
Roxas does exist his hearts inside my
heart the other Twilight town is just
data so what will else except light or
darkness I know I want to know well good
for you but guess what I won't let her
fall to darkness
[Music]
this key plate is that
Mickey you're too late
[Music]
exclusive
[Music]
[Music]
you needn't cower in the doorway I
actually like meeting new people
besides the conversation with my friend
here has reached a bit of an impasse I
think he just needs a moment to cool off
now
I sense that you brought me something to
inspect show me the waves of change
rolled throughout the Seas and a new
land is revealed the Forsaken shores the
place of darkness when fire and ash
consumed and from the depths skeleton
crews
cuz the seas
an ancient evil set loose upon the sea
of Thebes
you have to live hurt unto me a portent
of tone most terrible oh you just wanted
to know how much it was worth than you
fine I'll give you ten for it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
god this innocence then it there are
pockets office to honor that meeting
barn for today mighty storm
scarp nning our monster be vet at known
as
[Music]
[Music]
exclusive world premiere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to see me now is
because there's magic in
I can see
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
please welcome from playground games
Ralph
Fulton
[Applause]
thank you so much it is fantastic to be
here today I am excited to show you the
world premiere of Forza horizon for set
a beautiful historic Britain Forza
horizon 4 features dynamic seasons in a
shared open-world and seasons change
everything let me introduce you to some
of our team who will be helping them or
the game today please welcome Bill who
is online with a few friends in the
beautiful English countryside he has
chosen the incredible new McLaren Senna
and say hi to Solomon who is hanging out
with his buddies on the streets of
Scotland's capital Edinburgh Sullivan is
driving the hoonigan Ford Focus and
please welcome Andy whose off-road buggy
is perfect for taking jumps scaling
rocky terrain and having fun on the
coastline of Breton but first let's join
Rebecca she is enjoying the summer and
her highly customized Nissan Silvia
the Sun is out the sky is blue and it's
the perfect day for a drive for
summarize enforce Brinson is a shared
open world when you play you play with
the entire community and that means the
other drivers you'll meets in the game
will be real people with all the variety
and spontaneity and fun that real people
bring flesh join bel he's in the same
shared world is Rebecca driving at
speeds made even more thrilling on Xbox
one X by the brand's new 60 FPS mode
meanwhile Andy is bouncing around the
djinns nearby as you can see horizon 4
is still full of action-packed fun and
now we're going to show you how aizen's
change everything
[Applause]
in horizon for every season changes the
world around you with each springing its
own unique beauty and unique gameplay
one of the great things about this
shared world is that it's easy to
interact with the people you meet here
Solomon and Rebecca used the new quick
chat feature on the d-pad to start a new
friendship at Luke's leg Rebecca has
found some like-minded friends
[Music]
it's great to play solo but it's better
to play with others horizon for lets you
seamlessly answer co-op
from within the game worlds
seasons time of day and where their
conditions are dynamic but they are
synchronized for every player so the
entire community will experience them at
the same time
[Applause]
now as much as we'd all love to sit and
watch the Sun go down together let's see
how this scene Luke's in winter
the entire open world changes beyond
recognition in winter the lake has
frozen solids and previously
inaccessible areas can be reached the
trees and entirely lost their leaves and
snow and ice covered the terrain the
visuals and the driving experience
couldn't be more different and never
blimp has appeared over the ice to
signal the start of a new world event
Forsyth unlive invites the entire
community to come together and cooperate
to win big rewards
and while they head off to the event I'd
like to show you how the world of forts
on horizon for Luke's and spring
once again the world changes completely
with the seasons bringing new driving
experiences new gameplay a new events
across the whole world every season
there are new reasons to play Forza
horizon 4 and the huge creative
fun-loving horizon community will be
there to enjoy them with you
today you've seen a completely new take
on horizon and force a horizon for you
will live in a vast beautiful world in
which dynamic seasons change everything
Forza horizon 4 is coming to Xbox one on
Windows 10 on October 2nd and I am
thrilled to announce that it will be
included in Xbox game pass on the same
day thank you so much please welcome
back bill Spencer
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we know that exclusive games from our
Microsoft Studios or what originally
turned so many of us into Xbox fans my
team and I take our commitment to you
seriously to make Xbox one the best
place for you to play and for you to
have the best games on the world's most
powerful console this is why we're
increasing our investment in our
existing franchises that you already
love and this is why we are amplifying
our investment in new worlds that will
deepen your love for gaming on Xbox we
embarked on a quest a quest to find
creative teams that have the mastery of
our artform and we found innovative game
designers master storytellers
exceptional world builders and now I'm
proud to introduce the creation of a
brand new Microsoft studio the
initiative led by Darrell black
Gallagher a visionary storyteller who
has worked across some of the most
iconic franchises for over 20 years
this new Santa Monica studio is building
a team of world-class talent to create
groundbreaking new game experiences and
next I'm excited to welcome undead labs
to Microsoft Studios
this studio caught our attention with
their visionary approach to building a
Zombie Survival franchise they just
released their second infestation into
the world and in the first two weeks
over two million of you have joined the
fight to survive now it's my distinct
pleasure to announce that we have
acquired playground games this is one of
the highest-rated studios of this
generation celebrated for their
incredible craftsmanship
not only will playground games continue
to work on ports our horizon they're
bringing their open-world expertise to
an entirely new project we can't wait to
share more about that later and for the
fourth new studio it's my personal honor
to welcome ninja theory to my Kazuya
I met Nina to me we we collaborated on
kungfu Kaos back on the original Xbox
and a minute into playing hell-blade you
know you're in the hands of master
storytellers who are fearless about
telling bold cinematic stories
this is a team gifted in creating new
franchises and yes we've got a fit
studio to announce compulsion games two
years ago we premiered a game we
couldn't get out of our heads a game
that captivated us with its strong fresh
and intense storytelling we happy few is
release is is nearing its full release
to gamers everywhere so please help me
in welcoming all of our new studio
by joining us at Microsoft Studios these
five new teams will have the resources
the platform and creative independence
to make big take bigger risks create
even bolder worlds for you
truth is the enemy of happiness isn't
that the decision we all made oh but you
know the truth don't you
[Music]
there's not a thing I can tell you that
you don't already know is there have you
had your joy only people in town are
getting a tad bit skinny I think they're
starving today and their feet in the
street rainbows have you not noticed oh
please why are you all wearing those it
Achilles knew must get one they shape
your face into a smile and when you
smile you can't help being happy we have
to tell people they need to know the
truth no it's better not to know
[Music]
[Music]
father we've practically the only two
people in this entire city not still of
our minds and joined in terrible day
plan if you post people to have the
emotions you want the new tourism robots
made out of meat where is it where the
black boy
[Music]
people won't face facts not until we
take their joy and let me do that
they'll murder each other in the street
[Music]
exclusive
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
world premiere
[Music]
to normal
[Music]
to trust
[Music]
[Applause]
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
world premiere Washington DC the most
heavily protected city on earth
within its limits 177 foreign embassies
550 elected officials and 23,000
military personnel in the event of an
attack critical personnel are evacuated
underground shelters open while complex
defense systems patrol the sky but
nothing stopped the virus 27 days after
patient zero
Washington fell it began with riots on K
Street than shootings in the National
Mall troops withdrew to bunkers
civilians were left in the streets
America is on the brink of collapse but
some people have survived Gardens grow
on rooftops their fences patrolled with
rifles in communities that live under
constant siege survival has taken the
form of urban warfare centuries ago on
this very soil brother fought brother
spilling blood to forge the United
States history is threatening to repeat
itself now in the heat of summer six
months after the outbreak began a
remnant of a corrupt State lurks in the
shadows ready to engage in a new civil
war
agents of the division are the only ones
standing against it but how do you save
a nation when its enemies come from
within
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
not that crash site is just ahead
Duke KITT did you guys hear that
yeah closer this time
this parachute dropped right through the
ceiling let me see if I can get this
it'll come in handy see you guys are
coming or what yeah all right Merry
Christmas
here's the door
[Music]
[Music]
Karpinsky to the division okay let me
just talk to this guy okay meet us at
the sinkhole okay sure
[Music]
Wow okay definitely from the capital you
should have a new side mission on the
map yeah
we're not that far okay do it after the
crash site sounds good
they're just ahead of us Matt
[Music]
hey I see you I'll be up in a sec can't
we gotta get you leveled up I know
please help
I've been iffy toxic chemical residue
detected a lot of loot down there hey
you guys should really check this out
almost there so that's the control point
anyway for me they've pink yep my Sam
don't aggro him yet for me adjust my
build got my crossbow and chem launcher
can blot out Mac can you flank them and
get a clear shot
I'll take up sniper on top wait for it
got her
mapped out
all right let me try to get that tank
off you on the other side of the plane
grenade grenade it
I need your help over here
take your mind
I'm stuck
little help
thanks man oh there's a dude brushing
through the plane
yeah I'll see what I can do
got him down I'll cover you guys come on
come on
shut that weak points watch out
setting my Shero thank you for the
revive meg
I've got this guy but have a tank
map of the hive night I just lay it on
him
drop down
you're on your own
guy good job level up level 30 Oh
Congrats Flair is up control point is
ours
hey guys want to check out the plane
let's go analyzing ballistic residue
like our rough landing
that's nuts let's check it out great
idea let's just die
so gameplan take the capital back I
think we're ready three two one
[Music]
please welcome the head of engineering
Xbox game paths ashley Speicher
[Music]
[Applause]
this is a special time for gamers we've
never had so many incredible games to
play storied franchises uncharted worlds
new releases and cult classics genres we
love and genres we'd love to explore
there's only one problem too often we
are forced to choose one amazing game
over another so we set out to solve that
problem and to answer the question what
if you didn't have to choose what if you
could play them all the answer Xbox game
pass a way to give gamers the ultimate
freedom to play and your response has
blown us away not only are you playing
more games you are spending more time
gaming freedom of choice is leading to
more discovery more play and more fun
and we couldn't be more inspired to keep
building and unlocking more for you so
for the last year we've been working on
how to give you faster access to all
those games we leverage the machine
learning expertise we have at Microsoft
and invented a way to start your games
twice as fast and naturally we're
calling it fast start unlike the current
ready to start system which is manually
configured fast start uses machine
learning techniques based on how gamers
actually play games and fast start it's
designed to get better as the algorithms
and parameters are refined over time I'm
pleased to announce that fast start will
launch for select titles and the June
update coming later this month
[Applause]
[Music]
ultimately it all comes down to the
games will continue to deliver iconic
favorites like Halo the Master Chief
collection coming later this year we
also plan to release all new exclusive
games from Microsoft studios including
Forza horizon for crackdown 3 and more
into the Xbox game pass catalog on the
same day as their global release
[Applause]
[Music]
every month will also bring new games
from leading creative studios into your
xbox game past library games like ashen
Warhammer vermintide - after-party and
Phoenix point all available in Xcode
Xbox game past the same day as their
global release
so that's what's next but let's talk
about what's happening today Tom
Clancy's the division the the Elder
Scrolls online Tamriel unlimited and
fallout 4
all enhanced for Xbox 1x in gorgeous 4k
and all of them playable today in xbox
game pass
[Music]
thank you to all of the developers
working with us to bring freedom of
choice to gamers around the world with
Xbox game pass thanks everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
go
[Music]
[Music]
she flow
[Music]
[Music]
I thought I knew why I came here I saw
it at the end and now the truth feels
farther away than ever I've so many
questions
we can't let Trinity get hold of this
you realize the tragedy you haven't
reached the cleansing has begun it calls
to me now to stop it before it consumes
us all
what if I tell
[Music]
shame
I know that it's not practical I know
that it's hard to believe
[Music]
you don't know what you call solve this
Laura
you need to trust me
you have to trust each other
[Music]
[Music]
he wants to alter the course of humanity
if you had that power what would you do
[Applause]
[Music]
exclusive they say I'm like geese
Willison breakable dive hard to Cygnus
biggest mic on the tripod but I'm not
shouting bad breakup Scylla killer
imagine do the analog of the king of the
jungle animal instinct phenomenal
stamping is just think about a man on
the brink of insanity and asleep do not
a rapper you a movie star checking every
Barbie the booty on the table do this
for as soon regardless our marvelous
majestic go oh my power warning [ __ ]
well-spoken rider like a boat runs for
any small folks the harsh Nick everyman
see you this should be an MC masong
we know the powers
that's all we know exclusive they say
you only live once I beg to differ I was
born three times and I've met death
three times
my first home was Alton over
the curiosity I gained there cost me my
first life I awoke again in tariffs the
village of the sorcerers I once thought
that this would be my true home
everything changed when I started to
pass the forbidden questions
what exactly is the true nature of the
Blackstone what lies beneath the vast
desert who was it that was calling me
from the devil's beyond the desert
the world never paid heed to such
questions they just fought on blinded
and wounded from
the power it is time that I at long last
reveal the hidden secrets once
come to me if you dare to learn your
true wretched self
I am and Lazzara the darkness born from
the desert world première
[Applause]
we've known each other long time
[Music]
you never had this much trouble
you're gonna make do this
[Music]
hey honey the assistants
okay you have to hit every single bump
in the road oh my true
you're up trucha peanuts
yeah he's real pro at smacking Deena's
around that's why building that
well-functioning arm to kick demonex
[Music]
what no chitchat or monologue just
getting right to the point huh
Noblet a badass work is worth every dad
you know that tough
yes first
[Music]
gasps oh so that's done
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
please welcome from Capcom producer Matt
Walker and director Itagaki eat suno
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
as Victor I wait for years for this
thank you so much
the MC is back
English English needs the hard math you
they of course it's been 10 years since
Devil May Cry 4 was released and fans
have been asking for a true sequel ever
since so this is our response loud and
clear that we hear you devil may cry and
Hideaki it suno are back
early on in the development don't make
cry 5 we set our sights on creating
something that was going to have
world-class visuals so we've scanned
fully costume models for all of our main
characters and with the power of Xbox
one X we're able to render them as
realistically as possible
now while visuals are really important
the controls need to remain tight
responsive as well so we've gathered the
best minds at Capcom to ensure that we
can still deliver that amazing gameplay
that double May Cry is known for and we
think that we made something that feels
better than any action game we've ever
created horahora
say they all want law yeah yeah Samantha
many it's even much inside ready give my
staff a Stice tomorrow this Yost gonna
smash each Suzanne says that he is
convinced that this is the best game
that he's ever made because we made it
for you our fans and we hope you look
forward to seeing more
[Applause]
exclusive
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
exclusive
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that tiny fox in a big world is a prime
example of the reach of gaming today a
labor of love conceived and created by a
single developer in Halifax Nova Scotia
is today
commanding gaming's largest stage
whether you're sharing the adventure of
a tiny fox with more than 20 million
viewers on mixer or teaming up with Xbox
Live friends to slay zombies gaming is
an incredible community we've always
believed that building community is
vital for gaming there's real power in
our shared experience sharing the same
world the same seasons the same
campaigns and there's real meaning in
sharing our love of gaming with fellow
gamers this community is the reason why
we love premiering games here at e3 for
the rest of our briefing everything you
show you will be world premiere games no
one has seen before
starting off with something entirely new
from our friends at Bandai Namco on my
last trip to Japan their creative team
showed me a sneak peek at their next
game now you get to see the first look
[Applause]
[Music]
there are worlds that exist separate
from our own
where the impossible is reality
they consist of both good and evil these
worlds were never meant to meet but
things have changed
[Music]
now they have begun to merge as one and
our last hope are the heroes we could
only imagine uniting to fight for our
survival
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Jim fours
unite to fight world premiere it's been
15 years since the fall
the city is a corpse and we are the
worms we burrow in it
fighting for every useful piece of land
to preserve ourselves from the terrors
of the night and the horrors of the day
you can hear my voice but shall
therefore speak a word or two here
anyone who dares to steal food will be
hanged and their bodies will be exposed
every day we rise from dust to choose
between bad and worse
[Music]
these choices we take to survive will
create the world to come
you know the drill get to the nearest
safe house and wait until dawn good
night and good luck
please welcome narrative designer Chris
a below
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hi I'm Chris Avila and I'm excited to be
working with checkland to create the
world of dying light - dying light - is
everything you'd expect from a bold
sequel of the first game a fluid parkour
system with improved natural movement
deepened tactical first-person melee
combat and of course terrifying Knights
when the infected emerge from the depths
of the city to feed on anyone they can
find at the same time we invite you to a
new vision of the post apocalypse a
bleak and unforgiving reality that we
call the modern Dark Ages today however
we want to give you a look at one of the
impressive new features of dying light -
a technical and narrative advancement
for the franchise dying light - will be
the first at its genre where your
choices have genuine consequences in the
game itself
from how it looks how it plays to the
events that occur everything in the game
world can change based on your decisions
the following demo throws a bit more
light on this
[Applause]
by light to feature the functioning
ecosystem that reacts on multiple levels
the things you do and the choices you
make in the example we are about to show
you our protagonist undertakes a mission
for the peacekeepers one of the many
factions active in the city they want
you to negotiate with two survivors who
are controlling and hoarding a water
supply
final offer
let's say you choose to carry out the
peacekeepers order one way or another
[Applause]
after this you will start seeing a
significant change in the city as access
to the water supply allowed the
peacekeepers to bring stability and
develop the area
there's even running water for the
people at the street level and that
raises their morale and allows you to
replenish your energy on the go but
there's a cost to this the PKS have a
rigid approach to law and order so while
the streets may be safer it's only safer
for those who side with them so if you
get on their bad side
now let's return to that moment of
choice and instead of killing them you
choose to team up with this group to
supply water on the black market as you
will see this creates a very different
set of consequences for the city with
water being a precious currency it
brings you access to new resources and
trade but this in turn attracts the
worst type of people to the area
[Music]
and this is just a single decision one
out of hundreds you will have to make
but it allows you to carve out your own
world each player's game experience will
be unique and by the way this is just
what happens in the day at night
well things till they get a lot darker
[Applause]
exclusive world premiere a lot of time
is passed we've gotten soft complacent
you always knew this day would come
you always knew the three of you would
be needed again you always wait what
[Applause]
[Music]
a brand-new game featuring body morphine
genre mashups three player couch co-op
4k hand-drawn 2.5 D graphics and broad
nonspecific feature decorations
they're back
[Music]
[Applause]
world-premiere
I was born to fight wars that no army
could win there was no fear no failure
[Music]
but the rules have changed the enemy
changed and no one was ready for it
the black hunt they are the world's most
powerful private army but even they
should fear what they've created this is
in a war Rico this is survival
[Music]
[Music]
does that happen a lot what am I getting
shot at all the time
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
world-premiere
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
to grandmother's enough we'll deal with
this later Foss around these people up
they need help there's a place up north
I think we can find your answers there
no absolutely not
we have orders you'll go with me doc
damn it both of you listen I'll go with
her look if you're missing general
notice okay
I'll push jack the coordinates no
corporal you're coming back to North
IRRI that is a direct order
well captain screw your order this isn't
about you it's about me I need to fix
this
[Music]
Hey watch her a necklace that's a Lucas
symbol yes so she would never be heard I
meet my choice I know that because she
would die for us I know that but what if
it's not her choice
[Music]
[Music]
where are we going back to where it all
began
[Music]
who's in
who's ready
I mean
[Music]
Hey hey why did you come here with me
what did JT tell you
[Music]
[Applause]
in the entire history of Xbox in the
entire history of e3 in the entire
history of our industry gaming is now at
its most vibrant today we shared our
commitment to giving you the freedom to
dub discover and play all of the great
new games coming to Xbox game pass today
we showcased more games than we ever
have before 50 games 18 titles with
exclusivity and 15 world premieres today
we shared our most diverse gaming
portfolio in every measure from breath
and art style genre and culture's range
and subject and setting scale and story
and scope and creative vision and every
one of these plays best on xbox the
world of gaming in the Kazan and
historic growth path where the
increasing number of gamers is met with
the increasing creative power of game
developers in this significant moment we
are constantly challenging ourselves
where can we take gaming next our answer
we commit and harness the full breadth
of our resources at Microsoft to deliver
on the future of play our experts in
Microsoft research are developing the
future of gaming AI so the worlds and
characters we enjoy will be even more
rich and more immersive our cloud
engineers are building a game streaming
network to unlock console quality gaming
on any device
not only that we are dedicated to
perfecting your experience everywhere
you want to play on your xbox your PC or
your phone and of course our hardware
team the same team that delivered
unprecedented performance with Xbox one
X is deep into architecting the next
Xbox consoles where we will once again
deliver on our commitment to set the
benchmark for console gaming and let's
talk about our games themselves we are
committed to building an
industry-leading
first party studios organization and as
you saw earlier we are making one of our
greatest single year investments in
teams by adding five new creative
Studios we have committed our team our
company our technical resources so we
can declare to you today and next year
and all of the years after that you will
always experience the best in gaming on
Xbox
so choose the games you want to play
there are worlds to be saved heroes to
be made and legends to be come together
thanks and have a great
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in 2077 they voted my city the worst
place to live in America main issues sky
high rate of violence and more people
living below the poverty line than
anywhere else
can't deny it it's all true but
everybody still wants to live here the
city's always got a promise for you
might be a lie an illusion it's there
just around the corner and it keeps you
going
[Music]
it's a city of dreams and I'm a big
dreamer
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
cleaner
[Music]
[Music]
my playground
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]